[Music]
she's been struggling with weight for so
many years are you and your husband
overweight are you all super fit we are
fit cuz she does ask me Mom you got to
help me you want please help me I don't
want to be this way but then when I do
help her then she gets upset with me the
questions she's asking you is Mommy why
don't you love
[Music]
me hey everybody what's up this is John
with the Dr John deloney
show show we talk about your marriage
parenting emotional health your mental
health I've been walking alongside
hurting people for two
decades whether your marriage is falling
apart whether you're you've suffered
deep loss whether you just don't know
the next right thing to do or things are
pretty good you just think man I think
they could be
better this show is made up of real
people making phone calls and talking to
we we talk to each other real people
going through real trying times and I
don't know anybody myself included who's
not dealing with trying times right now
it's a mess out there and instead of
yelling and screaming and pointing
fingers and throwing
nonsense garbage advice at each other on
this show I promise I'm gonna sit with
you we'll figure it out and I got two
phds if I don't know the answer I've got
some friends that do um on today's show
I've got a special guest coming in to
talk to us about holiday eating we're
going to get real and talk about hard
stuff and that's the promise here if you
want to be on the show give me a buzz at
1844 693 3291 it's 1844 693 3291 or go
to John dooney.com
askk guess what I did last
night that's probably a bad way to frame
that because you never know I rewatched
with some friends and some other folks
hiy ho the original Hanky the Christmas
Poo Hank the Christmas
Poo
Masterpiece wow yeah it was old school
like 20 years ago oh longer than that
said the oldest person I know wow so
good that was I believe that was before
I moved to Nashville and I've been here
since 20 I was in college yeah so we're
talking
2530 wow you're older than you think you
are I was a toddler I was a toddler I
was a toddler U he so um if they're not
sold out yet and I keep saying that but
they I bet they're I bet they're gone um
if they're not get online and pick them
up the questions for humans Christmas
edition and we got the New Year's
Edition New Year's is my favorite
holiday of the year where the whole
country The Whole World's like ah you
get a mulligan like ah I fell off the
wagon last year and did a bunch of
terrible things like but it's New Year's
and everyone's like cool let's do it
again I love New Year's there's a New
Year's deck there there is a Christmas
deck if the Christmas deck's not sold
out it sells out every time but let's
run through a couple of of questions
from the Christmas deck Kelly all right
which gift from The 12 Days of Christmas
would be an actual nightmare to receive
and which would be awesome go ahead well
the awesome I would think you know five
golden rings cuz money bags McGee over
here mean jewelry you know who doesn't
love some jewelry gosh awful would
probably be most of the rest of them um
yeah all the birds all the Birds I don't
know that I want 10 Lords a leaping in
my house um you make us leap all the
time but you're not at my home that is
true you make a do it at the office
which is super HR issue but whatever um
seven swans of swimming I'm not real
sure where I'd put them yeah and I
bathtub I don't know yeah I mean at
least like four frch chance okay great
we're having chicken for dinner but I
don't I don't really know what I would
do with pretty much anything from like 6
to to 12 yeah I think that song is just
about like it's like an a poultry
appreciation song I'd probably take the
Rings too just to appease you a I would
take a partridge and a pear tree because
I can plant a tree that's nice you can't
when's the last time you plant a tree um
earlier this fall here we
go it's people do it not hard people do
it but does Kelly do it yes Kelly Kelly
works at the I would take the Rings too
and I would just give them to you
and then that would be like a a a yell
free day for me which would be cool
whatever be an anger free day all right
next one all right go ahead what is one
place real or fictional let's do one
place real and one place fictional
excellent that you would love to visit
during Christmas time oh man I would
love to visit um
Ireland I don't know why I just think
like well hey I'm going to say something
I don't know if it's real but uh if if
like giant red stags and and reindeer
live
there probably not I feel like I want to
see that in the wild I just feel like
it'd be beautiful there I think you'd
probably be closer to like Northern
Scotland of course you don't know the
difference between Scotland and Ireland
we've determined that before I mean M it
all ends up in a pirate yeah playing
back
pipes um yeah I want to go to Ireland
Scotland yeah what about fictional that
place is those are real places
so what about fictional uh I wouldn't
mind spending Christmas at Hogwarts it
looks like they they it looks like they
decorate it up nice there's food
everywhere there's like dragons and
snakes and stuff Prett fancy yeah that
weird dude that with the big beard is
hanging out yeah big H like I think the
whole thing would be pretty rad yeah
Hogwarts is my fictional no question and
then my real so I got to go to England
for Christmas once and it's it is
amazing um but I would like to go to
Germany to the original Christmas
markets that's my
goal and they have a Krampus parade a
Krampus parade yes yes and I really want
to
go I've got so many jokes I'm not making
right now what is the cramps parade
Krampus jimin Christmas what is it
Krampus k r a m p u s Krampus it's um
kind of a Victorian era and before he
was kind of the um cohort to Santa Claus
but the opposite so Santa brought good
kids money or fruit or toys or whatever
Krampus uh put the kids in a bag yeah
beat them with a stick and then drug
them to
hell man dude that's the name of our
band will Krampus U there's actually a
horror movie called Krampus and I have a
Krampus doll of course you do dressed as
you worship it I can imagine you
worshiping the Krampus doll no but it's
a it's a German folk tale and they do an
actual parade and it's like a thing over
there and I would love to go see it just
in person would be
cool America you think I make this stuff
up about
her I
don't I may fudge the uh I may I may
exaggerate a bit on her tattoo game no
tattoos
zero li.com net.org but she does murder
all right let's go out to H tone and
talk to Jason what's up
Jason what's going on Dr joh what up man
how we doing oh pretty good how are you
good good good what's up brother hey so
um I'm finding myself at 52 pretty much
in complete rebuild mode tell me about
it so the last couple years I uh I
struggled with alcohol I uh lost a
really good job I lost a wife uh during
that time I got a DUI um going through
that process
and I right now I'm doing real good I
have been sober eight months almost hey
all right and uh I'm I'm I'm I'm doing
fairly well uh I during that time also I
did not make some uh so good uh
financial decisions yeah so I'm pretty
much by myself not by myself I have my
children but uh just found myself just
kind of rebuilding and just looking to
uh see or or go through the process of
of of trying to do this and and just to
get in a better place yeah man
dude like I can't tell
you how proud of you I
am thank you I appreciate that well hold
on here like I'm not just blowing that
off I don't want you just to like
deflect it because you're good at that
you've probably been deflecting that
your whole
life right yeah I'm I'm fairly good at
that you're great at it because you
don't believe it you think I'm lying to
you so here's how I'm not not lying to
you
um you got hit so
hard actually you're a boxer that got
knocked out Stone knocked
out and that's when most go dude I'm
this is I'm not in for
this and you slowly picked yourself back
up off the
canvas and now you're standing up you're
clear eyed and you're have one hand on
the top rope and you're thinking about
climbing back in the
ring that is courage brother that is
courage that is
courage and most men quit and you're
not so I'm not blowing smoke at you dude
I'm not blowing smoke at all it's pretty
impressive um so when you say you lost
your wife uh did she leave you or did
she pass away um she left me she left me
okay so you lost a job you you lost your
wife you you kind of soft pitched I kind
of struggled with alcohol a little bit
and then I lost everything so I'm
guessing you didn't just kind of
struggle with alcohol a little bit tell
me a little bit about that no not
alcohol has has uh pretty much been a
part of my life uh my adult life how
come then it got real it got really just
it was just a norm I know but but most
of us most folks who drink like that
that the way their bodies figured out
how to not deal with how bad life hurts
so what does life hurt man you know uh
I'm still in that process Dr John I I
think I I struggled a lot as a child
um uh um my real dad he uh he really
didn't have anything to do with me and I
was adopted early by the man who I call
my father who um who adopted me when I
was six married my mother and um not a
terrible childhood but it wasn't it
wasn't the best either but I I never
really fit into I always felt like I
never really fit into his
family and um just struggled with the
acceptance part of
things and um I guess I just dealt with
it in my own ways throughout the years
and and never really addressed it you
know until now you know it just now is
when I'm really really wanting to sit
down and and and and figure out what's
really going on why why I've been that
away so for for so many years I I I
can't answer the whole question but I
can get pretty dang
close I'm sure you haven't done this but
I hope at some point you
will but I need to go back for just a
second and talk to six-year-old
Jason
who is holding the hand of a man who's
not his daddy but a man who's saying
I'll step in the Gap here if it's what
it takes for me to marry your
mama and everyone around you cheering
and you're supposed to be happy about
that yeah and God bless him he put food
on the table it never felt like home but
at least you had a roof and you had
food yeah but that six-year-old little
boy is still haunted by that one damning
question which is Daddy what was so bad
about me that you
left yeah he was just he was never there
to begin with that's what I'm saying and
I didn't I didn't find out who he
actually was till I was like 27 yeah but
it was a ghost he was a ghost right
right exactly but you've got your own
kids right yes four of them did you walk
out on them oh no yeah you can't even
wrap your head around it can
you I know I always been the best dad
but hold on none of us have none of us
have we've all struggled but listen
don't evade it you can't imagine walking
out on your kid no
no how the hell did your old man walk
out on you
yeah
right yes
sir and one magic thing about alcohol is
it plays a pretty good chemical proxy to
connect
ction yeah and so when we're lonely when
our body's screaming at us that
someone's going to leave someone's going
to leave alcohol does make that go away
for a while until it kills us right till
it blows up everything right like I used
to tell people for years the worst part
about alcohol is that it
works until it doesn't right exactly
exactly so I'll probably give you
several things I want you to do for
homework at by the time this Call's over
but I want you to write a letter by hand
hand on notebook paper on a yellow pad
go to Walgreens or Walmart or something
get a yellow pad and I want you to write
a letter to six-year-old
Jason and tell that little boy it was
not his
fault his daddy walked out because
something was wrong with his daddy not
him that was a good kid that deserved to
have his old man around take him to
Oilers games and Astros games even when
they were terrible back
then
right yes sir until you let that little
six-year-old boy stop fighting for
you you're going to always have that Gap
and then you got to deal with you're 56
right 52 how old 52 52 yeah so this part
sucks right at 51 and a half you decided
I'm done I'm getting sober I'm about to
lose I've lost almost everything true
it's time and there's that moment when
it's like the Rocky song is playing and
you found yourself you're like 100
pounds overweight you go to the gym and
you do that one hard workout and then
you look in the mirror the next morning
you kind of look exactly the
same yeah and and I struggle with that
too Dr John I I struggle with what I
call uh the need for uh instant
transformation for instant gratification
there you go you know and I I don't see
the results as fast as I would like to
see that's right and you're coming up on
the holidays holidays going to be lonely
this time around aren't they I'm I'm I'm
making things uh I'm making plans to
spend a lot of with my kids good dude
I'm so gosh I'm so freaking proud of you
and believe it or not there's one other
thing Dr John what's that uh so Mother's
Day of this past year I actually lost my
mother oh my gosh and I haven't I
haven't even found a way to grieve
her um we had U not not a real strong
relationship towards the end uh there
were some things that happened in the
past with her that I wasn't real proud
of or held against
her and I just haven't I hate to say
this but at the time when she passed I
almost felt relieved yeah hey don't
don't that's that's a very common
response and then you probably felt
guilty for feeling relieved right
absolutely yeah and it just goes in a
circle and so here's a this isn't going
to heal it but this is a good way to
start way to get out of the starting
blocks
okay do you have a pen with you I do all
right I do you have to write three
letters to mom over the course of about
three weeks one a week okay okay one of
the letters is how much I miss
you how much I miss you Mom I went
through hell this last year my wife left
I lost my job I'm finally getting sober
and clean and I miss
you I'm always going to miss you love
Jason and I want that to be a couple of
pages I want you to remember some fun
stuff y'all did as kids how she held it
together after your dad left I want you
to remember some good stuff the second
letter
is unfreaking believable
mom and I want you to tell the truth
when I was a kid you right I want you to
go all the way through the hard stuff
the anger dear Mom I'm really
mad and you know the things that she did
that you held against her that all that
stuff I want you to get that on paper
and here's the third
letter dear Mom I'm sober
now I'm growing
up here's what you're going to
miss you're going to miss watching your
boy Rise From the Ashes you're going to
miss your boy becoming the best dad of
all
time you're going to miss your boy Bo
becoming a success story going to the
gym getting his finances in order
meeting somebody new being the greatest
dad who shows up for his kids and then
being the best Granddad that ever
lived okay yeah I just uh I just had my
um my oldest daughter just had my second
grandson go so I'm I'm I'm ecstatic
about that yes and I don't want to say
this is a chance to do it over but this
is kind of a chance to reimagine it
right absolutely there you go
yep I'd love for you to start writing
that little those two little grandkids
letters so they have 18 years with the
letters from Granddad okay and let me
tell you this my grandmother passed away
a couple years ago I have tattooed on my
arm the last card she sent me in her
handwriting it says we love
you and I had them lift that that
handwriting and permanently put on my
body that's how much it meant to me that
letter from my
grandmother
and I want your grandkids to have a a a
whole thing and when your grandkids get
into some trouble when they're middle
school and high schoolers which they
will I want you to be able to sit down
with them in your 60s and go hey we're
going to Coffee we're going to pan get
pancakes at Waffle House I'm I'm going
to talk to you about some stuff I went
through and you're going to redeem your
story those bricks you're carrying
around you're going to take them out of
your backpack and set that crap down
it's over and then you're going to pave
the sidewalks that those kids walk on on
your story see what I'm saying
yes sir this is Legacy
brother this is how you change your
family
tree now I've I've thrown a bunch of
like instagramy stuff at you I'm gonna
make it pretty concrete okay is that
cool okay awesome yes here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna load you up but if I
load you up you got to send those uh you
got to send those letters right
absolutely all right I'm G send you both
of my Wall Street Journal bestselling
books you got them you already got them
I've already got them all right I ain't
sending you nothing
then all right so you already got them I
got them I'm going to send you Financial
Peace University for free I got that too
you got have you used it I'm starting
January are you gonna actually do it yes
sir do you have every dollar uh yes I
signed up for all that okay I I giving
you nothing then what do you need what
can I do I just I guess I just needed a
uh just a voice
reassurance that's what I
needed what do you really
need just you
know I needed another man to tell me
that I was head in the right
direction Jason you're a swimming
Upstream of a culture that tells you
you're washed up a culture that tells
you you're a failure a culture that
tells you ain't worth a dime
you're absolutely worth it every step
you
take are you gonna drink again no sir no
sir you got a job I do I do it's a good
job okay we gonna hang on to that
job I'm I'm GNA hang on to it but I'm
also uh I'm going to look for something
else that may be a little bit better
okay I I believe in my skills and and
and my knowledge and uh you're going to
be about you're going to be about
serving the customer taking care of
people solving problems you're going to
do work with Excellence right absolutely
that's what I do what I do and you're
gonna get that debt paid off so you're
free nobody owns Jason right exactly
you're going to write each one of your
kids a letter and say hey I wasn't the
best dad but I love you guys and never
ever doubt it I was going through some
tough stuff it was never about you guys
and I'm spending the rest of my life
being the best father that ever
existed
yeah you're worth it you're worth every
step of it my
brother every single
step I got something you don't have aha
we're going to send you grandparents and
grandkids the questions for humans
deck I'm going to mail that out to you
and that way you can chitchat with your
grandkids one of them's going to be way
too young but you can still chitchat
with them go for that and man I'm so
proud of you dude 52 having to look in
the mirror and start
over deal with your DUI it's going to be
expensive be honest with the judge take
care of your business there in
Houston don't ever drink and drive don't
put other people at risk you're better
than that don't put you at
risk let's make all the changes let's go
get them 2024 is a year Jason continues
his
journey 8 months in for the rest of your
life my brother I'm so proud of you
we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone this time of year
there can be a lot of anxiety and a lot
of drama but can also be great but can
also be a mix of everything right
especially when it comes to giving gifts
maybe your family makes super thoughtful
handmade things or they expect you to
spend a million dollars or maybe you
just like experiencing time together or
pick up random gift cards last minute
things like gift giving can make us
bananas so no matter how hectic it gets
especially around
giftgiving remember to take care of
yourself whether it's going easier on
yourself during tough moments or having
to say hey we don't have enough money to
buy all these gifts or treating yourself
to a Day of Silence remember to give
yourself some love this holiday season
and if things get too heavy if thinking
about dealing with your family and all
of the drama gets to be too much give
Better Health a try better help is
flexible because it's online so it can
fit into your busy holiday schedule just
fill out a short questionnaire to get
match with the licensed therapist and
you can switch therapists at any time
for no extra charge in this season of
Chaos in love in sadness and all of it
rolled up to one give yourself what you
need with better help visit
betterhelp.com dealone today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp h
lp.com
dealone all right let's roll out to
Tampa Florida and talk to Amy hey Amy
what's up hey Dr John thanks so much for
taking my call of course what's going on
hey so I'm gonna go ahead if it's okay
and read the letter that I submitted um
how do I know when to let my 13-year-old
daughter control her own health and
nutrition she's been struggling with
weight for so many years we have tried
everything everything um you tell
parents how we put bricks in our back in
our kids backpacks all the time so how
do I help her do I stop and if she gains
600 lbs do I make it that's her choice
I'm tired of talking about food and
exercise all the time all the time she
can't put a piece of food in her mouth
without feeling judged so I'm not
looking for nutrition or exercise help
from you how do I let my daughter know
she is seen and she is loved and she is
not judged where does she get that
message that she's being
judged um well I've noticed over the
past year so that um she goes and eats
in her room she'd prefer to eat in her
room because then she she actually said
if I go and I have my meal in my room
then I can eat in peace and I don't feel
like someone's looking at me whether
it's me or whether it's Dad or her
brothers um because of her weight gain
over the years I'm trying to help her
with portion control and you know better
choices and making sure we have healthy
food um but I just feel like just her
personality her demeanor she just I
don't know she just she gets mad she
asks me if I get mad at her like if
she's still hungry and she wants seconds
she's like well are you mad because I
want seconds are you mad because I put
too much salt are you mad because I
chose you know I don't know I just um
how long have you been after her for
this years at least four years she's
probably gained 100 lb in the last four
years what changed in her life four
years
ago um school got rough and Co made it
you know worse um so she was home a lot
had a lot more access to food and it can
be healthy food it's not just you know
junk food that she loves toat it can be
healthy food that she just likes to eat
what happened what happened at
home um I don't know I've thought about
that because I I had a feeling you'd ask
I can't really
pinpoint any particular thing um that
may have caused
it are you in your husband overweight
are you all super fit we are fit we are
fit and um she knows that I had
struggled with weight when I was her age
and kind of got that together 30 years
ago and yes we are very and that's the
thing we try to set a model for her that
we have healthy foods her brothers are
fit we all exercise daily
um and then you know I've encouraged her
it has to be something she likes to do I
like to run she's not a runner her dad's
not a runner so I'm like let's do
something fun we put her in classes
gymnastics we play tennis we dance she's
big into theater um I
just I don't know and I guess I guess
what I really need your help with this
is do I just let her do her own thing
because I I find myself every time she
is eating looking at what she's eating
and how much she's eating because she
does ask me Mom you got to help me you
want to please help me I don't want to
be this way but then when I do help her
then she gets upset with me because she
doesn't like what I have to say or if I
restrict her and tell her that's because
that's not the question she's asking
you okay the question she's asking you
is Mommy why don't you love
me
H and kids don't know how to ask that
question and so they say are you proud
of me do you like my Straight A's did
you see that goal I
scored did you see how I lost five
pounds they're not asking you to look at
the scale or look at the soccer ball
they're saying am I finally enough am I
enough
now yeah and whether it's genetic
whether it's learned behavior whether
it's all of that stuff
combined it sounds like your daughter's
been asking for a long long time do
y'all love me and and when she gets an
answer that's conditional mhm she goes
to the
behavior again whether learned whether
genetic whether
whatever
um that makes her body her shoulders
drop finally and then it starts the
shame spiral again and then she starts
saying does anybody see me does anybody
love me it's kind of like I don't know
if your husband does this but when you
say man I had a really rough day and
your husband says well let's just call
him let's call him right now and let's
tell your boss that
he's not hearing you because what you're
saying when you say I had a really rough
day is not I had a really rough day and
since you're so smart and wonderful
husband will you solve my problems for
me that's not what you're saying you're
saying do you do you still love
me and I think for a long long long time
your daughter's known she's not good
enough she's not doing let me say it
this way she's not doing it
right whatever it is she's not doing
life
right and she watches her brothers get
praised she watches you and your husband
praise each other
and that little part of her body in her
brain says we're not welcome
here and so no I think it would be a I
think you all have gotten into a dance
over the last four years and probably
started before this and here's the
dance
she comes in and gets something to eat
she catches you you wise she catches you
glance out of the corner of your eye and
she knows I'm being judged I'm out of
here or I'm going to eat this and the
only thing that makes her feel better is
eating again because she doesn't have
access to alcohol or cigarettes or sex
or any the other stuff that make that
that grown-ups use or
busyness
and then when she goes into her room she
hears you and is this enough mom well I
wouldn't the it's just a dance what you
all need desperately is professional
intervention not on the Food Part will
come you'll have to address that but
what you really need
is she's got you'll have to go through a
season where she knows you and your
husband love her no matter what and that
can't just be saying we love you yep you
see what I'm
saying and I hate having this
conversation with moms especially
because moms take this hard as though
you failed something right
yes and you try to make it right by
[Music]
overcontrolled wheel it's not good
parenting right so you find yourself
stuck and so what I would tell you to do
is you got to learn a new way to
interact with your
baby yep now as I'm saying this does
that ring true or tell me how I sound
like I'm out to lunch
no it does it does ring true and um I've
tried a couple of different counselors
okay um I'm I'm not a fan of therapy Dr
John until I started listening to your
show why wen't why weren't you a fan I'm
not I just I always raised you don't we
fix it in the house you know I was
raised in a Christian home and you know
we pray about things and we fix it um
within our home and and that's it gosh
dude that's so damaging I hope you know
that now yeah I mean I've learned a lot
of things and um it's just such a
different relationship though the way I
was raised and I you know as as a parent
you try to do the right things that were
right in your home and um you know I've
never had any issues with my boys as far
as you know that kind of thing and
parenting but okay so I want to tell you
something I'm going to use the word
trauma and don't don't over respond to
that because I'm not saying there's any
trauma in your house
okay but I've mentioned I think I
mentioned this on the last episode I
just shot um one of the guys I did a
practicum with
gave me some Lang he one time I we were
look talking about some some kids we
were working with and I said well that
one's going to be okay and he looked at
me and said hey you know that straight
A's can be a trauma response
to and some kids their biology is
heavy some kids they're um they say do
you love me and they set something on
fire and other kids go make perfect
scores on things and they say do you
love me
and we Pat one on the head and we give
send one to college for free and we put
the other one in
jail the
response is the same I'm sorry the
response is different but the underlying
pathology is the
same you see what I'm
saying yeah and we have I mean I and
even though you know I'm I'm definitely
open I've learned a lot from listening
to your show and you know I have a
friend that I've talked to that you know
I've basically said you know I just gosh
I wish I could just fix her I wish I
could just fix the way that she wants to
be and I had a brave friend say to me
one time she's not broken yes she's not
a project she's not a project to be
fixed and so who told you that about
you uh told me I was broken yep um I
grew up I grew up with a father who was
very critical of my
weight so yeah that was and my brother
jumped on board a couple of times and
you know thought it was okay because if
Dad said it and Dad's in charge you know
then it was you know it was like fair
game in the house so but I you know I'm
I'm good I come to terms with all of
that and I got it together you know
probably in my 20s when I just um it
worked for me and I figured it out hold
on that's the language you got to be
careful
of I quote unquote got it together
because then you pass that on your
daughter get it together yeah right yeah
and often when guys go to AA and they
quit quit drinking they all start
smoking they trade one for the
other and if you traded food for I'm in
the gym seven days a week and I count
every single morsel of every you just
traded one for the other you might live
longer but you're
not I can call you healthier
metabolically but you haven't addressed
the core problem that your dad you were
never
enough or your love to your old man was
conditional on how you looked how your
plate
looked you see what I'm saying
y yep and listen Amy this is a guy with
two phds because I had a really really
Sant smart sister and a brother who
missed two questions on the ACT and I've
been desperately chasing the question
will y'all tell me I'm smart too cuz I
was just a dumb
jock I've been chasing and chasing and
chasing until finally I just quit and
had to deal with
it and come to find out it was a bunch
of stupid stories I was telling
myself yeah but here's what we're doing
we have go ahead go ahead sorry I was
just gonna say we have I have um I got
our counselor came highly recommended um
unfortunately about two months in she
doesn't need one okay y'all need one she
will that's what I'm figuring out is
that it's not her y all it's the dynamic
in her home that she does not have the
tools to
address so instead of saying why are you
eating that or are you really hungry or
can you substitute that for something
healthier M ask yourself what is her
body trying to protect her from in her
very own
home okay and it might be the way
everyone's looking at her or it might be
that she only gets talk to when she
after after the workouts
over
or it might be
dad or she hears dad and brother making
fun of the overweight girl on
TV see what I'm saying yeah her body is
trying to defend her in her own home and
if y'all had alcohol where she could
access it she she's on a she'll get it
soon and if she finds some boy to tell
her that she's beautiful she'll man
she'll be all over that
too she just doesn't have access
yet this is about defense this is not
about your daughter's broken and so
maybe for a season look at her and say
her body's working
perfectly what in the world is it trying
to defend her
from and I'm also not one of these guys
who says like has F jumped on this
bandwagon it dude our health in this
country is a train
wreck yeah it's not
good and I'm not I would be lying to
somebody and dishonoring them if I said
not being obese is great it's not every
part of your day is
harder every part okay so that's not
what I'm saying here but what I'm saying
here is to get to that part in a healthy
way you'll have to address the system
inside that home and I think your
daughter may be a an alarm system for
the
home does that does that ring true or no
um yeah I think in some parts it does
but in I and I think you know that's
that's what I'm looking for that's kind
of the answer I was looking for for you
was I I'm realizing there is nothing
wrong with her it's the way you know I
see it or I address it or my husband
sees it or my husband addresses it
there's there's absolutely nothing wrong
with her so but I just
feel I feel horrible that as her mom she
doesn't feel like safe in our home like
I get that I get that I totally get
that I can't think of a more devastating
thing to feel and I felt it because I
was told that
and the people who told me that were
right I was a nuclear ball of energy in
my daughter's body a little bitty baby
girl who was 5 years old B bopping
around my house said that dude is not
safe I didn't hit her I didn't yell I
don't raise my voice in my house I was a
great
dad but dude I was a nuclear
reactor and so I think I think the
here's the conversation I think I think
the conversation begins with um hey
honey I I don't even know where to start
other
than we've created a home that's just
not safe for
you and we've wrapped it up in doing all
the things perfectly but in trying to
achieve all the perfect things we've
made a very unstable house and I'm
sorry and I don't know what to do but
here's my promise I promise I'm going to
work on
it and I think your whole family needs
to go to a family counselor all of you
together and there has to be a family
counselor that's willing to take you and
your husband on because my guess is
y'all are a force of Nature and they
need to be able to take y'all
on
an needs to be able to honestly address
your
daughter because she does have some very
unhealthy
habits it's both
and but I wouldn't send her to a
counselor and be like she just needs to
get fixed and I wouldn't go to counselor
if I was you and just be like I need the
right thing to say to my daughter so
she'll eat better no dude her body's
trying to protect her from a house that
lets her know has let her know for a
season ah you're not really enough for
us you got to fix some stuff then you'll
be on the inside like your
brothers and God Almighty I know how
hard that is to hear I've I cringe as a
parent saying that to another parent
because I know how hard that is to
hear but the the evidence is the pattern
for four years you've tried a thing and
it hasn't worked and your daughter's put
on 100 pounds in four
years let's throw up our hands and say
okay what I'm doing is not
working let's try something
else but I know how devastating and and
um um fatal disorder eating can be and
so I would go see somebody ASAP
professional in your
area for you for your husband for your
sons and for that sweet girl yours and
along the way I want you to address the
fact that you were only loved when you
looked right to your dad let's let this
thing stop right now this is what Legacy
and family tree change looks like thanks
for the call Amy we'll be right
back if you've listened to my show any
amount of time you've definitely heard
me talk about thorn thorn is an
incredible supplement company that makes
what I think are the best supplements in
the game I've taken Thorn for years way
before I had a show as you've probably
heard from listening to other podcasts
or just walking through a local corner
store there are a million different
supplements all claiming you're the next
great thing for all sorts of ailments
almost all of those claims and products
are either lying not good products are
just a waste of your money Thorn is one
of the very few supplement companies
that make Pure Clean tested and backed
by science supplements no fluff no
gimmicks no nonsense Thorn is what I
take personally and it's what I give to
my kids and make no mistake supplements
of this quality cost more than the
nonsense you see in gas stations so I've
partnered with Thor for an incredible
25% off discount for our deloney show
listeners go to thorne.com
delone choose what you want add it to
your cart create an account and when you
check out 25% off will be knocked off of
the entire order and here's the best
part that discount sticks around for
Life go to thorne.com
thelet
/one check it
out all right we are back and we're
talking eating around the holidays now
here's the the deal there's always um
ideas like YOLO like bro you deserve it
you've worked hard this year eat
everything and also there's the other
side which is the you never stop
grinding 24/7 365 I don't care what day
it is no celebration you put the cookie
down and there's guys like me who are
like I
what what I like pumpkin pie and I like
turkey and I like lots and lots of candy
I don't what to do so
I'm calling one of the smartest men on
planet Earth when it comes to nutrition
science my great friend Dr Lane Norton
is here to talk us all through eating
around the holidays what's up
Lane what's going on John how you doing
buddy dude I'm doing great thanks for
stepping out of your uh Beefcake 2000
training session to talk with us
man well I left the deadlift bar I'm
gonna go pick it right back up no
worries I left the deadlift bar you know
who said that today nobody but Lane
Norton
only probably I am
unique you know what I think that's
gonna be on your Tombstone Lane Norton
he was unique just kidding um it's it's
nothing else brother no it's gonna be
amazing father and a guy who helped
millions and millions of people Chang
their life me being one of them man um
hey thanks for coming on can you um dude
just I need some No Nonsense just
straight to it mothers and fathers who
are not in like the yo bro not in theut
nutrition space family sitting around
the table over Thanksgiving and into at
we're post Thanksgiving by the time the
show comes out into the Christmas
holidays there's gifts there's cookies
there's holiday parties there's all the
stuff can you give us some sort of
Common Sense approach for navigating
eating around the
holidays yeah so I think you know you
kind of touched on it earlier there's
there's like two spectrums right on on
one hand you've got hey you know one
meal is not going to hurt you enjoy it
don't worry about it have whatever and
aside Spectrum you've got um you know
grind 247 you know so whereing between
these spectrums you follow kind of
depends on like you know what's your
goals what what do you want to get out
of this um I you know I'm not a feelings
based person when it comes of this stuff
I'm very data driven and so you know on
the one side when people people who say
the eating is in Oculus and don't worry
about it that's actually just not
supported by the data um if we look at
the amount of weight people gay during
adulthood per year any depending on the
study you look at anywhere from 50 to
90% of that comes in the six weeks from
the end of November to the beginning of
January which is what a holidays Lane
don't don't say that okay hold on real
quick can you talk can you talk directly
into your phone
dude yeah sure so oh perfect okay hold
on I need you to stop saying what you're
saying because what you're saying is I
can do really good for most of the year
and just kind of get off the rails
between uh October and Christmas and the
data says that's where most adults gain
most of their weight on an annual basis
that is correct so anywhere from 50 to
90% And the research suggests that they
don't they don't really compensate the
rest of the year most people kind of
maintain the rest rest of the year and
the data is actually worse for people
who are overweight or obese they tend to
gain even more weight during the
holidays and so like obviously you know
if you can just m i want to tell you you
just maintain during the holidays you're
kind of ahead of the game um and I think
that should be the goal for for a lot of
people not trying to like lose fat
during the holidays but just focusing on
like healthy
maintenance um but there's a lot of
barriers in the way the first off is if
we look at the food that's eaten during
the holidays uh s like in data in the
studies it is actually more calorie than
the food we normally consume so you're
you're getting more energy per you know
weight of food um and then if we look at
the data around eating in groups what's
really fascinating is when people eat by
themselves they eat significantly less
than if they eat with a partner and it's
not a linear effect but the more people
that are involved in the eating the more
people tend to consume it's like this
behavioral trait we don't really quite
understand oh I understand it clearly I
feel awkward in social situations
especially around people I only see once
a year and one way I make myself feel
better is by
going and eating and eating and going
back to what you're saying about caloric
density you can't just eat sweet
potatoes during the holidays you have to
put a metric ton of butter and
marshmallows on them duh what's the
matter with you and you can't just have
turkey like a cereal killer you have to
have
bread doused in Turkey parts and then
turkey juice like yeah you're asking us
to not be human Lane right and then if
you look at you know it's not just one
meal we're really what we're talking
about is a series of meals during the
holidays so without doing an actual
thesis on this and giving your listeners
some some quick action things they can
do um the first thing is like stay
mindful so that is like if you you
decide hey you know what I'm just going
to enjoy this I'm not going to worry
about it that's fine the tradeoff with
that is you may gain some body fat you
probably will gain some body fat if you
say if you're somebody's a little more
diet attuned and you say you know I'm
not really worried about that I can take
it off later in the year that's cool no
problem I think for most of us we don't
really have that mindfulness we kind of
go in like we just jump out of the plane
and we kind of hope we got a parachute
on so we'll kind of eat whatever but
then we just to send up a hope and a
prayer that you know nothing bad happens
but but but but the but the data tells
us the science tells us and this is you
talking to me you've never told me this
before hold out by the way um
that most of us most of the time will
put on 50 to 90% of our weight for the
year in that those last few months and
then we just hit a new plateau and we
just maintained for the rest of the year
and that's how you look up 5 years and
10 years later and suddenly you're 10 or
15 pounds heavier than you were a decade
ago you you can trace this back to a big
chunk of that being of course the
knick-knacks throughout a week
throughout the year but a big chunk of
it is getting off the rails in the
holidays enjoying yourself having fun at
the holiday parties having fun with
family and friends on multiple parties
and then just holding steady the next
year and then doing it again and then
holding say the next year and just doing
it again suddenly you wake up and you
find yourself in a tough
spot that's good that's correct um and
again like you know we're talking we
talking about data we're talking about
averages of course of course of course
some people will say I didn't go right
during the holidays it was all doing
some of barbecues for me okay well we're
again we're talking about for the for
the average person that's right
so the actionable phe to do I think the
first thing is realize that you know a
lot of your Ramsey listeners are going
to be familiar with keeping a budget
yeah you know uh calories are kind of
you know kind of like a
budget um you know so if for example you
could be great with your your calorie
budget all week but if you go crazy on
the
weekends um you know it's still going to
blow your budget right that's right so
you have to be mindful now when it comes
to holidays again we're talking about
usually series of meals so what I
recommend to people is if you know that
there's an event coming up the first
thing is like if you know you've got a
dinner don't don't go out to breakfast
that morning right and then don't have a
really heavy much like try to keep it
lighter earlier in the day so that you
got you've got some more flexibility in
your budget for later yes then when it
comes to uh your actual meals you know I
don't I food order doesn't really matter
that much some people make a big deal
about it but I would say you know when
you're making your plate at a Holiday
meal you know most people are going to
give you a bunch of Guff because I know
a lot of people say well I want my
family to give me a hard times and I'm
not eating
okay we'll make a plate but you know one
try to choose like Lear proteins so
maybe like you know ham is actually
relatively lean uh and then white meat
turkey or a mix of white and dark meat
so you've got some leaner proteins on
there you know eat those first they tend
to be a little bit more satiating can
kind of dampen your hunger a little bit
as you head into the more less filling
things um know try to get some
vegetables in there that's also going to
be filling and then like hey have some
of the food you want have some of that
you know sweet potato with butter you
know have some of that stuffing and have
some dessert but you know make you know
just tell yourself one thing I tell
people is you just have one serving okay
you can have one serving feel like a
totally normal human being and you you
know listen to your satiety cues okay if
you feel full there's no reason to keep
eating I think another thing to keep in
mind is liquid calories
and this is where you know one alcohol
consumption is higher during the
holidays yeah so if you know you're
going to be drinking either alcohol or
another form of liquid
calories um those tend to not be as
those aren't really satiating liquid
calories don't tend to satisfy us so if
you're not a big alcohol person which
you know if you're listening to the show
we probably don't recommend that right
you know maybe focus on your food and if
you do want to have a couple drinks
maybe you're sing out saying okay well
you know I'm gonna omit the starch today
or I'm gonna omit the dessert today
because I am G to have a couple drinks
like these are tradeoffs right just like
if you were doing a budget okay you know
um I want to go take the wife out to
dinner it's going to cost you know 150
bucks and so that means you know I'm not
going and playing golf two two days this
month something like that right so
you're exchanging yeah that model um
when you told me that privately just in
a private phone call that model was
transformative for me when I begin to
think oh I've got $2,000 I can spend
today so it's not a matter of can I eat
that cadburry egg or not of course you
can it's just going to cost you $600 and
you only have 2,000 to spend and do you
want to have that steak that your wife
is making tonight because that's going
to cost you 1,200 bucks because it's a
ribey it it's fantastic um now you're
down to like an apple right so when I
just begin to think of it as a budget um
not in the dramatic way or I can't do
this kind of way dude and I love the
advice um man when I when I'm
conscientious and I ask myself this
question am I really hungry or am I just
eating because I'm uncomfortable when I
just ask myself that question sometimes
I'm like nope and I'm having that pie
anyway fine my rule is I never fall off
the wagon but sometimes I'll step off
the wagon and roll around in the mud and
climb back onone fine I've got to I got
to pay the piper on that one
but I find myself mindlessly eating
around family and friends and awkward
situations I don't know what to do with
my hands so I just grab something and
that idea of there's a budget and am I
really hungry right now and dude let's
eat the proteins first just as a simple
it's not going to solve all your
problems in a dramatic YouTuber kind of
way but it does help right it does help
fill me up a little bit and gets me
going that way so dude those are some
great great great tips man
um any last like one truth bomb you can
leave us
you've already ruined my uh Thanksgiving
so
thanks and I would say like hey like you
know I'm not telling people you need to
bring a food scale and track your
calories or anything like that like just
you know mindful reasonable portion
sizes if there somebody that does
struggle with like oh you know I like to
have something in my hand okay you can
have water or you know diet soda you
know God for bid I know there's a lot of
people who don't get Mia about this we
don't have time to cover the research
but if you want to take my word for it
the research in human studies where they
control appropriately 80% of studies
show that diet soda is perfectly safe
and the 20% that don't are mostly weak
correlations that have a lot of
confounding variables so and if we're if
we're uh using the one white analogy
which is shoot the alligator closest to
the boat if that diet soda even if it's
not ideal if it makes you more
comfortable and you end up like not
eating you know 2,000 calories of
whatever then that's a fair that's a
great tradeoff dude so hey I think
that's my that's my that has been um you
know I've talked offline using your
carbon app which is the best app in the
game um I've I'm down 10 pounds and it's
not water it's not keto water down it is
it's 60 days slow losing body fat and
one of the things that's kept me in the
game is either Coke Zero or Diet Coke or
Stevia and I know all the diet um witch
Hunters are going to come after me for
that but the data is the data is it the
most healthiest thing no not at all but
does it keep me on the path yes and what
I'm find here's what I'm finding 60 days
in I'm using it less and less and less
right as I make my transition so it's
not the enemy of progress be Perfection
that's such a big thing yes so many
people feel like they've got to get this
stuff completely perfect the first time
around and they won't let them it's like
I've got it completely clean never cheat
and what ends up happening is when they
ever they get exposed to this kind of
stuff they go crazy because they haven't
learn how to moderate and I think one
more thing I'll add is like you know if
you fall off the wagon so to speak no
shame don't beat yourself up figure out
well have a conversation like why did
this happen what can I do in the future
and then move on um and if you're going
to have fun Foods
pick Foods you really enjoy don't waste
it on stuff that's just for grabbing
stuff and one more thing limit your
snacks try to limit your food to your
meals the research actually very clearly
shows one of the biggest characteristics
between people who lose weight and keep
it off versus those that don't is people
who lose weight and keep it off they on
average don't Smack very often
because acts are less satiating and you
tend to remember them Less in fact when
you look at the
research people under report their
caloric intake by about 50% on average
so and by the way they do the same thing
to debt by the way right right right so
it's not that people are lying it's just
that we have rose-colored glasses and
when you if you ask somebody hey what
did you eat yesterday you remember your
meals but you probably don't remember
your snacks the cookies and the Kit Kats
and all that kind of stuff yeah dude
that's that's that's incredible but dude
I'm going to let you go dude I'm so
grateful for you get back to a working
out beef cake beef cake but dude um
thanks for being my friend um for
everybody out there um please if you're
considering like a like hey I'm going to
actually take this thing seriously to
the next level and use data carbon app
the carbon app is the best it's what I
use it's what my manager uses Kelly's
got it it's just the best it's the best
um it's the best
and I just recently Lane found the
barcode scanner part of it that I don't
even have to punch it in I can just scan
the barcode with it's amazing all I have
to say is thank you so much for being a
one of the best in the business and a
close friend and a guy that um helps me
through personal challenges that I have
behind closed doors I'm just really
grateful for you so this holiday season
be mindful enjoy yourself have fun
if if you don't want to be around your
family don't just stand there mindlessly
grabbing things and eating them go
outside tell everybody you got to go go
take a nap in the back room sing I don't
know what you got to do just be mindful
we'll be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at john.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's
show everyone's favorite segment am I
the problem all right let's do it Kelly
you ready let's do it all right am I the
problem my husband and I were talking
about his cousin and the guy she married
they aren't doing well in both suffer
from addictions he doesn't have a job my
husband started to voice that he wanted
better for her someone that would whine
and D her and take care of her remind uh
mind you that my husband doesn't do any
of that for me either which is probably
why I got so hurt but he says that she's
like a real life Barbie and he expected
better for her side note I have brown
hair green eyes opposite of Barbie and
now I'm hurt there are so many layers to
this honestly we were in a cult-like
church and he was getting desperate I
truly believe that he settled so that in
the back of my head I think he wishes he
had the Barbie am I the problem whoa
there's there's lots of problems here
hun
so
oh yesh sounds like husband made a
comment
and that evoked an
entire uh Lord of the Rings
trilogy just the the three-hour version
of each one and the the double a last
one um and maybe that story's comes she
comes by those stories naturally because
her husband's just not great but if you
find yourself so am I the problem yeah I
mean kind of um but also that sucks that
he's like she deserves this this and
this and you're looking at your husband
like uh you don't do any of that
stuff the fact that you couldn't say uh
honey you don't do any of that stuff
tells me there's more challenges in your
relationship because you're not able
just to call it out so if anybody finds
thems in this situation I always advise
unless somebody's not safe let that
situation pass because nobody wins if
you go to war in that situation I know
people are like you got to dress it
right then that's dumb it's dumb but you
need to go out and take your husband to
breakfast or lunch and say hey you said
some things about your sister I feel
like you settled when you married me I
feel like you said she deserves to be
whine and dine but you don't ever whine
and dine me so maybe I don't deserve it
and put that stuff out there put that
stuff out there because it's circulating
in your relationship I don't know what
do you think Kelly yeah I think the same
thing I'm I'm very curious about the
part where she said they were in a
cult-like church and that she felt he
felt like he had to get married I can
see where that would maybe think like
well so I was just available yes but um
need to have a very hard conversation I
think yes um so I don't know that
anybody's a problem here as much as but
I will say this everybody I did it this
morning waking out of bed bed waking up
out of bed this morning in that little
Haze I start I thought I had a thought
about work today and I just went down a
road like I don't want I can't even
freaky and then I started laughing and
go nope not doing that and I didn't have
to yell or anything I just said stop and
I got up and went and did my morning
stuff so stop with the oh he just
settled and then this and then this and
then this and then this dude don't do
that don't do that you're just GNA make
yourself bananas be in N so just have
the hard
conversation does that sound right
yeah I I think that's really all there
is to it I think the whole thing's a
problem yeah all of
it but dude by the
way I mean this with all due
respect if your husband's
talking better about his sister than
you y'all should probably have that
conversation hey see y'all next time
love you
[Music]
bye